[Music]
okay everybody now listen carefully
we have to make our objectives very very
very clear
the muslim community and not just the
muslim community but all those
who have witnessed the atrocities of
this terrorist apartheid state of israel
are not here to cause provocation we are
here
to alter a narrative hold the map closer
please
we're here yes much better much better
we're here to show the world
that we are standing by the people of
palestine those who have been oppressed
in the occupied land
how dare the international community
how dare the international community not
take decisive action even after
those areas which are not recognized as
part of the state of israel by the u.n
those areas are being occupied and
colonized in the modern day
how dare so-called liberals
people who believe in equality so-called
equality of opportunity
and so-called equality of race how could
you stand and watch a state
just like south africa an apartheid
space
and
that have been dealing with a minority
population
in the way that israel is dealing with a
minority population
what would the international community
do are we to believe
that the international community would
stand ideally
[Music]
is
[Applause]
and if these idiots as these zionists
believe that we will faith
fade away into the context of our eyes
and that
what they've done to those children that
their deliberate targeting of civilians
then they are mistaken they are totally
closely mistaken about that we are here
standing in the streets of london in the
heart of london
to proclaim with all of humanity and all
figure
that we will never ever leave the side
of the palestinians
and if you think that our people in
palestine
or across the arabian muslim world will
let go of this struggle in our sacred
places like al-aqsa
you are grossly mistaken
it will never happen
or do you think this would be allowed to
take place
this kind of protest or would it be seen
as
inciting hate it would be seen as i'm
fighting right
but we have a state like israel a state
which is promised and predicated on
occupation
and colonialism a state that is a racist
state
a state which officials candidly say
that they want to install
layers of jewish people in their
provinces which don't even
they are allowed to say what they want
because it serves america's geopolitical
interest
and we say you can say what you have but
the world no wonder is going to buy your
orientalist narrative
social media has changed the game the
internet has changed the game the people
are too loud
the people are too many the muslims are
too many
and we will never ever allow you to
write your poison
narratives again mainstream media is
dead
mainstream media is that and we will
shout
at the top of our lungs
to support them
you see one more thing i want to add
here
one more thing i want to add those
zionists that came into this protest
those scientists that came into this
protest with dogs into our area
the quran even tells us there's a group
of a tribe to attack the prophet
they won't fight you all together unless
they're in fortified towers
or behind walls these are your ancient
tactics you pathetic
bruce lee pusha animuses so to wrap up
i say this here i say this here today
15 million views on just about the same
topic
that's level that is
[Music]
in just the last two weeks and that is
double almost double the population of
the so-called state of israel which has
a 9 million population
it seems to me that the missiles that we
need to throw
our intellectual missiles our social
media missiles our narrative changing
missiles
online throwing those palestinian flags
on
every single comic book sharing lagging
and doing that belief you me
we have numbers we are muslims we have 2
billion people on the earth
so we must be active on the internet and
we must be as loud as possible
and let me tell you this once and be
unequivocal and unambiguous
in my directive here no one starts
violence
but if someone if someone comes to you
try
if someone comes to you then you know
you can apply the reasonable force
foreign